I bought a a Toyota Prius which is like
a good responsible thing to do the fuel
efficient uh hybrid yes but it was more
like for like financial reasons I had
one if it sound cool like I bought it
for like the environment but it's cheap
to buy gas but the thing is I parked it
outside my friend's house and I walked
out and someone had keyed the word gay
on the hood of the car really I'm not
kidding man in like huge letters like
just gay like right on the hood of my
car you know I don't know I like didn't
know what to do and all these teenagers
would walk by and kind of point and
laugh at me when I was at a stopwatch
and I was like so I sat around with my
friend and I like literally just for
hours just how can I make this different
so my theory was I keyed not on top of
the game
check it out ladies ladies not gay
and then I would do the ride totally on
top of that totally not gay I don't want
to see my not gay ride